Salut ! Je suis en pleine forme, je ne suis même pas fatigué
donc je peux continuer à faire une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Je plaisante ! C'est par rapport à la vidéo d'hier que je dis ça.
Et aujourd'hui c'est le jour de l'astuce de la semaine.
Astuce que vous m'avez demandé dans les commentaires il y a une semaine.
A savoir : comment clore une discussion avec un bavard.
J'ai trouvé que c'était une bonne idée surtout quand on est quelqu'un de gentil,
on n'ose pas trop vexer la personne en lui disant "tais-toi, ne n'en peux plus, ça ne m’intéresse pas !"
Est ce qu'il y a des astuces pour ça ? Et bien oui monsieur ! Oui madame, il y a des astuces.
Première astuce, il faut vous engouffrer dans une brèche.
Dites-vous qu'il n'y aura pas de fin à la conversation, vous le savez, il sait que vous savez,
ou il ne s'en rend pas compte, et ça aussi ça arrive.
Donc profitez d'une petite brèche d'un moment où il respire,
oui parce que même un bavard respire à un moment donné,
pour prendre la main et expliquer que vous n'avez pas le temps.
Mais attention ! Expliquez-le poliment.
En racontant par exemple de manière succincte ce que vous avez à faire, ou ce que vous allez faire, ou ce que vous étiez déjà en train de faire.
Car ça ne les arrête pas que vous soyez en train de faire quelque chose quand ils ont envie de vous parler.
Mais comme on l'a vu dans de précédentes vidéos, le corps dit beaucoup plus que les mots.
Donc envoyez des signaux corporels.
Le premier signal à envoyer c'est de ne plus regarder l'interlocuteur dans les yeux.
Regardez autre chose, faites autre chose en même temps.
Bougez également, physiquement. Ne soyez pas statique à coté de la personne.
Soit de marcher, soit de ranger quelque chose à côté de vous.
Faites autre chose en même temps. Même quelque chose de futile, peu importe.
En clair, soyez actif dans autre chose que la conversation et non pas passif à écouter, à recevoir le bavard qui n’arrête jamais.
Si malgré ça, ça ne fonctionne toujours pas, alors il est temps de passer à une étape supérieure.
C'est-à-dire, exprimez clairement que c'est la fin de la conversation.
Mais comme la première astuce, faites-le poliment.
Sur une des micro-failles, coupez le et dites poliment: "c'était vraiment un plaisir de te parler,
maintenant j'y vais car j'ai ça, ça et ça à faire."
Ne lui laissez pas le choix. Encore une fois, un bavard ne se rend pas compte qu'il est bavard.
Ne se rend pas compte non plus, que ce n'est peu être pas le bon moment.
Ou n'a pas envie de s'en rendre compte. Peu importe.
En tout cas il faut que vous repreniez la main en mettant un terme à la conversation.
Votre ligne de conduite, à chaque fois que vous amorcez quelque chose, soit d'exprimer que vous n'avez pas le temps,
soit de clore la conversation, soit de la détourner une dernière fois.
C'est d'être affirmatif et déclaratif.
Si vous n’êtes pas affirmatif ou déclaratif, ou si vous n’êtes aucun des deux,
dans ces cas là, ça va être une faiblesse, et vous allez lui rendre le pouvoir.
Et forcément si on lui rend le pouvoir, le bavard il le garde !
Avec vos proches, c'est un petit peu plus subtil.
Les proches c'est la famille, les amis très proches.
C'est pas forcément d'ailleurs qu'ils sont toujours bavards.
Parfois, parce que ce n'est pas le bon moment, ou vous n’êtes pas encore disposé à écouter, ou vous avez autre chose à faire.
Il faut alors être un peu plus subtil. Il faut respecter deux choses :
1/ Il faut écouter la personne un minimum, savoir de quel sujet elle veut vous parler, et d'écouter un peu sur ce sujet là.
Vous ne pouvez pas clore la discussion si elle n'a pas pu réellement commencer ça devient mal poli,
la personne aura l'impression de se faire bâcher, c'est normal, ça vous ferait exactement le même effet à vous.
Et la deuxième astuce, la deuxième subtilité est de définir un temps défini dès le départ.
Mais de le fixer vraiment verbalement.
Ecoute moi bien... tu as 2 minutes pour me parler !
Je ne vous demande pas de faire ça, de prendre un chronomètre ou un minuteur...
Mais juste de notifier la personne à l'aide d'une phrase un peu maline.
Par exemple : "Oui je t'écoute, par contre seulement 5 minutes. Tu vois, il est 16h25,
à 16h30 je dois partir absolument donc vas-y dis moi en 5 minutes."
Définir le temps dès le départ, permettra de ne pas paraître impoli au moment de clore la discussion.
Donc les deux clés avec votre famille, vos amis proches c'est d’être poli,
de penser vraiment à la politesse, donc écoutez un minimum, définissez le temps et expliquez pourquoi
et d’être sincère. N'inventez pas une fausse excuse.
Si c'est parce que vous êtes simplement fatigué, notifiez la temporalité en expliquant
que c'est parce que vous êtes fatigué, et que vous allez vous coucher, vous allez regarder un film.
Mais n'inventez pas un excuse. Vos proches le savent c'est désagréable.
Quand on est à leur place c'est aussi désagréable. Donc il faut penser à ça.
J'espère que ces quelques conseils vous serviront.
Si vous aussi, vous connaissez un bavard, et que vous avez une anecdote là-dessus,
vous pouvez me le dire dans les commentaires, je les lis tous
et j'y réponds en général plutôt en fin de semaine, mais je réponds à tout le monde.
N'oubliez pas avant de partir de laisser ce silencieux, mais très efficace... POUCE EN L'AIR
Et surtout abonnez-vous à la chaîne avant de partir, parce que le MentalVlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17 H !
Ciao !